lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
digamos abordar desde un panorama muy
general lo que es el sistema endo
membranoso en las células eucariontes
porque entonces hablaremos del sistema
en done membranoso y a grandes rasgos el
sistema endo membranoso es el conjunto
de membranas que interactúan entre sí
dentro de la célula así que uno podría
preguntarse bueno y de qué membranas
estamos hablando y quizás deberíamos
empezar a hablar de la membrana celular
verdad digamos es esta que tenemos aquí
pintada en verde y en realidad todas las
membranas tienen una bicapa de
fosfolípidos verdad de hecho vamos a
hacer por ejemplo un acercamiento
digamos que tenemos aquí un acercamiento
de esta membrana verdad
y vamos a hacer en este cuadro un
acercamiento y entonces lo que vamos a
observar en esta membrana es en realidad
una doble capa verdad de fosfolípidos
aquí tenemos una parte de esa capa de
esa doble capa de hecho que tenemos acá
la otra parte entonces siempre vamos a
encontrar digamos de apuntando hacia
afuera las cabezas hidrofílicas mientras
que apuntando hacia adentro verdad
tendremos colas hidrofóbicas verdad
entonces por eso es que nosotros decimos
que esta es una bicapa verdad y por
supuesto esto puede extenderse en ambas
direcciones esto es una bicapa de
fosfolípidos y esto esto será
exactamente igual también por ejemplo
para la membrana celular la membrana
nuclear externa muy bien por ejemplo
vamos a pensarla aquí
esta es la membrana nuclear externa
verdad y aquí de hecho vemos dos
membranas verdad uno podría decir bueno
a lo mejor esto es una
capa de fosfolípidos pero en realidad no
en realidad son dos capas de
fosfolípidos verdad cada una de estas
verdad lo vimos en el vídeo anterior se
ve exactamente de la misma forma que lo
que hemos pintado acá verdad tenemos una
doble capa de fosfolípidos de hecho voy
a pintar por ejemplo aquí con magenta
aquí estamos
remarcando con magenta lo que es nuestra
membrana nuclear externa muy bien y esta
membrana nuclear externa de hecho
continúa verdad hacia el retículo
endoplasmático y por ejemplo si voy a
pintar por ejemplo con morado vamos a
poner con morado esta que tenemos aquí
por dentro esta que tenemos aquí dentro
es justamente la membrana nuclear
internamente verdad entonces todo esto
es parte del sistema endo membranoso
verdad y de hecho ya hemos hablado de lo
que ocurre en el retículo endoplasmático
verdad de hecho aún damos al respecto en
el vídeo anterior verdad tú eres parte
también del sistema
en do membranoso de hecho lo que es el
retículo endoplasmático puede
representar hasta el 50% o más de las
membranas fosfolípidos asociadas a la
célula y ya hemos visto lo que ocurre en
el lumen del retículo endoplasmático
verdad el lumen del retículo
endoplasmático es justamente esta parte
dentro del retículo verdad toda esta
parte es el lumen y ya hemos visto lo
que ocurre esencialmente hay síntesis de
proteínas principalmente pero también de
otras moléculas como por ejemplo lípidos
verdad entonces también ya vimos que las
proteínas verdad van del retículo
endoplasmático rugoso pasan al retiro
endoplasmático liso y después salen
verdad del retículo endoplasmático a
través de una zona que conocemos como
retículo endoplasmático transición al
muy bien entonces este será el retículo
el retículo endoplasmático trans y
transicional
vamos a escribirlo bien transicional muy
bien ahí lo tenemos
en realidad el retículo endoplasmático
transicional es justamente toda esta
zona verdad toda esta zona a través de
la cual las proteínas van a poder salir
ahora en general las proteínas no van
del retículo endoplasmático ruth rugoso
perdón hacia el liso y después al
transicional sino que a veces van del
rugoso directamente al transicional
verdad que sería como un pequeño parche
especializado del retículo
endoplasmático liso muy bien el punto es
que una vez que salen verdad salen en
este en estas estructuras que conocemos
como vesículas que esencialmente son
compartimentos con una membrana verdad y
en la cual pueden transportarse las
proteínas entonces aquí también tenemos
una membrana verdad también ésta está
hecha por una bicapa fosfolípidos ahora
después del ridículo en doblado en dos
plasmático transicional las vesículas
pasan verdad hacia el aparato de golgi y
hemos mencionado que en el aparato de
golgi verdad estas protege
pueden madurar y de hecho de hecho para
que puedan madurar aquí contamos con
muchas enzimas ya estas enzimas les
llamamos enzimas de enzimas de golgi que
por ejemplo lo que pueden hacer es
agregar zachary 2 a nuestras proteínas
por ejemplo pueden pueden volverlas
ahora unas glicoproteínas y en general
pueden hacerle cosas a las proteínas
para que sean útiles ya sea en la
membrana celular verdad que es en donde
pueden digamos anclarse o bien que sean
útiles en el exterior de la célula o en
otras partes de la célula entonces lo
que vamos a tener lo siguiente verdad
teníamos nuestra vesícula con nuestra
proteína está esta vesícula digamos la
membrana que delimita la vesícula puede
digamos fundirse con la membrana del
aparato de golgi una vez hecho esto la
proteína puede entrar hacia el aparato
de golgi verdad en donde va a madurar
por ejemplo se puede volver una
glicoproteína y después será envuelta
nuevamente en
digamos porción de membrana verdad va a
estar aquí
digamos en esta especie de saco para
después poder anclarse en la membrana o
salir fuera de la célula o bien
dirigirse a otra parte dentro de la
célula muy bien ahora bien no son las
únicas partes que cuenta digamos el con
las que cuenta el sistema endo
membranoso verdad también tenemos este
tipo de estructuras que tenemos aquí
abajo que conocemos como vacuolas y las
vacuolas són organelos acotados por una
membrana de la misma digamos de la misma
forma que hemos mencionado las
anteriores y por ejemplo en células de
plantas pueden usarse para almacenar o
bien pueden usarse para dar estructura a
la célula verdad porque incluso pueden
llegar a ser bastante grandes ahora bien
en el caso de las células animales
tenemos lisosomas verdad y estos
lisosomas son estructuras comen con con
membrana donde van digamos distintas
cosas para ser recicladas o
descompuestas así que no se digamos que
aquí tenemos una vesícula más viva lo
mejor voy
una vesícula muy grande pero es para que
quede claro la clara la idea verdad y
digamos que aquí tenemos alguna molécula
alguna proteína digamos entonces que
después esta vesícula verdad la membrana
de la vesícula se une con la membrana de
lisosomas para que nuestra proteína
quede dentro del liso soma ahora bien
puede ocurrir que dentro del lisosomas
tengamos un ph más bajo eso va a
provocar que éste organelos pueda
digerir esta esta proteína o esta
molécula verdad para obtener material
constituyente entonces vamos a quitar
eso y va a quedar
su material constituyente verdad que a
lo mejor puede ser útil para otro tipo
de procesos y bueno todo esto es parte
del sistema endo membranoso y espero que
esto te dé una gran idea de que tan
complejas y hermosas pueden llegar a ser
las células